hey guys mkbhd here back with a review
or more of a preview of what google has
released a lot more information on
recently and that's their new Google TV
platform
we'll begin our look today just by
taking a quick look at the promo slash
advertisement that Google released for
it on their YouTube channel what this
advertisement shows is that Google TV
will be available in two distinct
separate flavors you can either buy a
brand new television that has Google TV
built in and it'll have the smart Intel
technologies and have the actual
processor inside the TV for you or you
can buy a separate desktop box that you
can put and use with your current TV
both of these options will give you
everything you're looking at now which
include string music via Pandora to
multiple speaker systems in your house
or using different applications like
Google Chrome or the built-in Android
gallery or a whole bunch of other things
something worth noting is that all this
information is available at google.com
slash TV and I'll include a link for
that in the description as well as a
link to what you're viewing now which is
on the Google YouTube channel
you can see if the applications here
look very very similar to Android though
they do seem to be built for their only
platform like the Twitter application
here or catching up on stats while
you're watching a game like the NBA
gametime game built specifically for
Google TV and large televisions they'll
all be available for shop in the Android
Market straight from your TV all of this
information and much much more is
available at google.com slash TV which
we're going to go ahead and take a look
at now stretching across the bottom of
the website are a whole bunch of
clickable links all of these links
contain information to really help you
get to know Google TV a lot better from
the fact that there are applications to
using your Android phone as a remote so
why you would want to get Google TV in
the first place and where you can
upgrade and the cool thing is Google
really spent a lot of time on the site
so it's professional well made and it'll
also give you a lot of information
regarding the Google TV experience
literally clicking on each one of these
will give you a good idea what it will
feel like to own a Google TV
if you're not already convinced you're
gonna want a Google TV consider this
applications like this that run in the
Android Market will also run on your
television and you can even use your
existing Android phone as you can see
here just like an Evo 4G an application
can actually control your TV there are a
whole lot of things even in custom TV a
homepage for everyone who owns a Google
TV that is very customizable even with a
dedicated YouTube application all of
this and more make it a great idea to
look into Google TV if you haven't
already